a hairspray to get your life together
I'm not touching
everything you get at a gas station
pretty much doesn't work except for gas
severa dick bills gas and dick pills
Oh syrup dick pills uh uh
dude you're [ __ ] Ford really yeah
you're busting the Dodge Ram oh dude
yeah they [ __ ] work dude you'll [ __ ]
start a bird scooter on some of that
stuff bro one of them bust on uber
driver you take that stuff yeah be
careful man the one with the rhinoceros
on it it's for endangered species I
think I think that's right now it's just
horn in it Oh bro one of them may turn
my dick into a damn snuffleupagus bro
make you mine starts sniffing grabbing
things [ __ ] do man dick sneeze after
one of those things Joe but what am i
took I couldn't even turn my neck I
remember I was down in Miami and uh got
a couple I'm invited this girl over
couldn't even turn my [ __ ] neck and
she had to go home dude you blew up your
traps sometime puts the blood in the
wrong area like you put mine in my
[ __ ] hands oh yeah I said swollen
hands and feet oh I'm just a lip just
some [ __ ] I just sitting there my
dick had nothing to do it but my hands
are jab yeah just standing there like
frickin like like from Pullip skin gee
it's your girl's bday you gonna take
some of those dick pics really yes get
some of those dick pills hold on boss
nuts come on here my girl Sam is an
obvious euphemism for a guy let's be
honest bro how do you not catch this
[ __ ] man you do it bro I want you to
yeah sure most your life I thought Sam
you know if it's a guy or girl I don't
give a [ __ ] cuz I'm he's busted nut
sounds like he's doing a lot of it well
for her birthday where you think of
dinner come oh she's going out of town
are you seriously talking like that we
talked about that's how him and his girl
do man go to the state shuttle you said
that yeah much more appropriate term
they're talking about see you am out
here I called his wagon I think on stage
huh I don't know she likes it or not
the
come ass Togo wagons Oh see that's the
kind of stuff that you can say but I'm
sorry yeah not I come sores try comma
tops what about the little color boy you
take it it comes are us because you call
it the coming boy it just did you look
lumber boy oh you make her sound like a
little prison victim tell me more about
your ladies something nice for his team
all ski she's going to her birthday
she's going back to mames be with family
oh no the main uh [ __ ] northeast cat
come on dog Britain using his mad skills
locate you just gonna be shooting blanks
into the wall huh be busting an ass on
probably dangerous Brown better watch
the [ __ ] out you hear me bro oh the door
locked about time somebody blasts in him
instead of she's probably taking on the
low yeah that little frickin fuse artist
I'm sure he's probably testing a fuse
right now somewhere he's gonna be
blasting some old socks I think I see
your future now what did you girls
birthday on em how old 29 oh good that
was a trap question yep I like that and
see legal seriously what are you gonna
get her you guys care about gifts or no
no I mean trips we're gonna go on a trip
that's it
go to Santa Barbara Oh trip next year
huh me for your birthday yeah pretty
much I mean what Dean is these days huh
you didn't get me [ __ ] for my birthday I
have text week I'm still here on this
[ __ ] trap house every week I give ya
as you hang up more shoes and pictures
of yourself in the background I don't do
this so it does all this [ __ ] get this
yeah buddy this [ __ ] bus lamp though
yeah that takes the first prototype
somebody should fill that thing up here
it's filled it up for aa quarter full
baby Wow you know ways to go contribute
it looks a little long and get that
little Tater Tot in there for buffalo
wing it
ranch it's like the [ __ ] bus laughs
that's another thing going to our bus
lenses different types of neat things
put a Cinnabon in yours see what
happened yeah be cool time to pay the
bill you know that transformation
Brendan and I know glad to bring this up
right now with everybody you know I know
you're going through a lot and I know
you aren't a lot of different you know
you look like you were kind of you know
making a change in your life and you ran
out of money what do you mean a sex
change whatever you want say a
transformation is it's important part of
our lives and careers
we're always evolving growing which
makes life interesting deal and our
sponsors of this king in this thing Wix
invites you to tell the story of your
career transformation visually by design
your new homepage on Wix I wish I would
have done this man this is a cool
competition we're encouraging King and
the sting riders to build their most
imaginative creative homepage on a
homepage that highlights why your career
journey is unique just like the yep Wix
is a special place you can do this right
now and look Brendon if you're gonna get
a transformation you know do it online
you got a do or people can see it yeah
you right right but back to the
competition if you go to wix.com slash
go /k ATS and you start your own Wix
website it's free and then you design
your homepage tell us about your journey
show us your website and send the link
of your homepage to Wix WI X loves cats
K 80s at gmail.com Wix loves cats at
gmail.com yeah and then Theo and I will
review the best submissions from you
guys and we will announce the grand
prize winner of the Wix business VIP
premiere plan free for one year of value
$420 that's where are you gonna get that
hitter you're gonna get that vet that
package give it to them one more time
that's wix.com slash go slash cats
submit the link of your homepage to Wix
loves cats at gmail.com yeah and get it
right get it tight do what you want to
do rebuild your life get it right get it
time remodel yourself wix.com slash go
slash
it's time to buy few more pants look I
could be stealing something right now in
your neighborhood not in my neighborhood
brokes I'm part of a group I'm talking
about a neighborhood watch group
neighborhood watch me steal your [ __ ]
bobbies nah bro nah bro the neighborhood
watch is now an app on your phone so you
ain't stealing really usually it's like
somebody out there like in a raincoat
and with armed flashlight now the apps
called neighbors and it's by the ring
that company behind those cool video
doorbells and security cameras with the
neighbors app you receive real-time
crime and safety alerts deals trying to
steal your durables your cats whatever
yo man mister steal yo gerbils it helps
you stay informed about what's going on
your neighborhood it's completely free
you don't even need to own the ring
device really nah man download the
neighbors app set my home base in
neighborhood and just like that you're
ready get alerts from yo neighbors yep
the fact is it this app is making it
easier for neighbors to work together
and keep the community safe so you know
what's goin on you got the footage you
got the accuracy there's millions people
using it it's like the new neighborhood
watch powered by real people so if you
want to see what's going on your hood
techs cats pod que ATS pod to the number
five five eight eight eight five five
five five five five eight eight eight to
download the neighbors at today that as
hats pod two five five five eight eight
eight k-8 ESP OD two five five five
eight eight eight and starts to get that
experience of being a part of your
neighborhood watch know what's going on
who's doing this who's got a pizza pie
who's stealing something who's not who's
weird
yeah make your hood safe today with the
neighbors that buy ring gang someone's
got to pay for Brennan's coffee habit
what do we got let's go you guys wanna
kick it off let's kick something dude
awesome man we'll start with a little
clown my hound boy oh yeah something not
a dog you know I'm saying clown my house
let's do it alright these first two you
don't kick me to shake them with your
foot once if they really been [ __ ]
everywhere this first one is Lea aka
snaggletooth that's a dead dog right
Coco Danno Doc's cheese in like a
[ __ ] was it the friendliest
looking dog of all time this is
obviously before and after
panda fries yeah passed away clearly on
the right and also the tricking you know
this better than anyone come from New
Orleans that might be a good-looking rat
yeah you know I'm saying some people
just have rats for dogs but they don't
have a clue yet they don't they do a
nutria and they grow that face hair out
yeah and he's doing here at some time
you think it's a it's a dog and it's a
nutria why that dog has a friendly face
and eyebrows I have no idea but I [ __ ]
with this dog any facts on this little
[ __ ] pooch uh no we don't have any
facts on Lea the snaggletooth
unbelievable the researching done and by
a snaggletooth though this thing looks
like a little [ __ ] bra be honest with
you dude this dog dude okay first of all
in the first picture
yeah it's living it's also sitting on a
towel on someone's lap in a passenger
seat a real diva you know [ __ ] second
of all it's dead in the second picture
gave up look at that thing gave up on
life
and it's not so cute that right one
either leave this [ __ ] snaggle teeth
yeah I think this thing could do more
for itself you know I don't trust this
hell yeah leo bruh nah fam also he looks
like you'd lose a match with a rat I
messed this thing and it's Lee on the
left and alia on the right [ __ ] gang
It's A Wrap don't touch me rip all right
P on this IP a pound dog what else we
got here we can't love every animal son
and Lea gotta take an L bro someone got
steak you know yeah
[Music]
you've been taking it too easy for life
show me a dog just doing something
that's out there yeah I like my dogs a
couple wrinkles on its face that thing's
living too [ __ ] good yes Malibu hound
yeah that's at Malibu homeboy up next we
got javi the Husky and Oso the small nut
and they're both males
oh that one's humping the other one's
face I got a monkey is that our boo they
got any audio with it [ __ ] the other
ones there people are weird bro what's
happening here's the thing about Huskies
as big as they can get it they're the
West Hollywood dudes of the [ __ ]
hounds there's no way to zoom in on this
at all nah since the video we can't one
of them is a little hat on huh
I can't what kind of dogs on the left -
is that a small mutt the little one
that's a monkey yes it looks like a
honky
yeah you got to learn about animals
whoever sent this in who sent this in
Xavi hey that meant that might be a
large squirrel [ __ ] a husky which is
actually pretty cool when you think
about it dude this is like uh it's kind
of like lilo and stitch a little bit but
for [ __ ] you know it seems outlandish
I don't even want to watch this kind of
stuff it seems like a deleted scene from
Noah's Ark it seems like seems like a
deleted scene from snow dogs yeah bro
this looks like [ __ ] get these little
delinquent hounds off my [ __ ] face
what else you got yeah don't anybody
have a decent animal out there they
don't have a nice thoroughbred hound
these days hashtag America peace ooh the
cat this is peace ooh the cat
oh that's what's up yeah that he's a
little too relaxed for me but I [ __ ]
with that what do you mean he's - relax
dude he's a cat I like to keep my cat on
guard bro he's a little too comfortable
in the home they're also same color as
the pillow yeah but that's alright those
are other cats that came before was
probably his grandparents hello its
family tree I love Easter what's his
name P su and it means piss and finish
gang bro piss and finish lot of cats
piss and dudes I'm not shocked that he
went with that moniker um yeah this is a
beautiful white cat dude and I like to
see you know everybody's ripping white
people in the media these days I like to
see a white something white that's doing
something you know and people aren't
[ __ ] ripping him up there's you know
ninety-eight percent of whites are great
and this is one example of it right here
this little gato called blanco papa yeah
that's that pure Columbian right there
just that pure white cow juice also nice
[ __ ] fur bro I think look at the
first two proud to be white looks like
he's a [ __ ] white supremacist a
little too relaxed I'm saying with the
pink and the eyes I don't I don't trust
him either
cross just any of these animals I trust
this one dude dude on what was his fur
cut with baby powder brother [ __ ] look
at his pupils though bro no I stuffed
that cat into my nose bro that cat looks
like you don't [ __ ] keep you up all
night you know what I'm saying make some
bad decisions you saw best cat oh boy
I'll do that cat off a strippers back
boy you filming that little Cinderella
right there yeah that's another hitter
in it what else you got Dee here's an ad
from the king of the sting look if you
need to get a taco you need to get a
massage you need to get this or that
guess who can help you not me right
postmates scams
yeah and I'm that Kido kid so if I need
some eggs I need some meat at midnight I
hit up postmates to go what's up keto
kid and they deliver it right to my
house dude I'll take your house bro oh
yeah house no I'll do I'll catch with my
mouth bro post Bates 24 hours a day 365
days a year they will bring what you
need which I'm up Oh mate and this is
Brendan who once told me there was only
340 days in a year so I thought so bro
they lied to me they lied to me bad
calendar Brendan dude back down to
brand-new video post mates doesn't miss
dates download the app for your phone
for free browse local restaurants
businesses and track your delivery in
real time that's right into our King and
the sting supporters right now
post mates and us is giving the
listeners one honey nollans
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days so you got to get on the app
you got to download it and get that
hundred in your system snacks on snacks
on snacks start your free deliveries
download the app and use code ka TS two
zero one nine four one hundred dollars
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days yeah anything you need
anytime you need ice cream cheese bacon
sushi sushi
Hido tires whatever get what you want to
end your grill download post mates and
save with the code k 80s 2019 buzz buzz
post post support the podcast your dick
ain't right boys sneeze your hair bro
it's summertime they can hear right do
it you know what I'm saying bro you
gotta you gotta you gotta tighten one of
them up at least you got to grow your
dick out or grow your hair I got about
50% and I can't have no hair no dick
otherwise you got to grow a bunch of
hair pubis over your dick like the old
dudes in my gym yeah hide your dick no
way those times are gone you also don't
want to be wearing a hat all the goddamn
time yes
66% of men lose their hair by 35 go to 4
hems calm a one-stop-shop for hair loss
skin care and dick wellness for men time
to tighten up your Johnson burn a lot of
you guys out here with that leaky short
Johnson you got that lettuce for a mop
top up there it connects you with real
doctors men right solutions
I met a guy the other day no hair on the
top of his head sideburns only like who
the [ __ ] are you Josh yeah it's like the
assless chaps of haircuts bro you can't
do that bro listen hymns connect you
with real doctors medical great solution
to treat hair loss well-known generic
equivalents to name brand prescription
to help you keep your hair it'll be
furry as [ __ ] did the neighbors will be
patting you you'll be bright you'll be
[ __ ] in the ditch brother looks like
an Ewok by the time
you see man there's no waiting room no
awkward doctor visits get your a walk-on
you hairy little [ __ ] hairy MUPs
dude we're gonna [ __ ] cornrow your
[ __ ] back and neck your little bit
the corner or your Chester like I mean
Ian listen to trial month for him for
five dollars today right now while
supplies last see website for full
details safety info this would cost
hundreds if you want to look like you're
gonna be Jewish by the time we can tell
what you [ __ ] follicle here we sell
drugs in the valley slash cats that
sport is dot-com / K 80s for mor hims
dot-com fo r hims calm / k 80s harry
trying to keep lights on up next we'll
do a little debate club you have to Bay
Club boys first this is from Andy from
Newport News Virginia
Brendan T Oh what up gang gang buzz buzz
coming into this video here two three
and outs on the last two drives trying
to get first down here let's try it
again my first two videos weren't funny
enough for you got a little debate club
for you let's go with what is better the
National Football League or college
football Brendon especially pertains to
you I was just wondering maybe trying
out for nose guard for the Patriots next
week you know so I saw what the scales
were saying about just so dude here's
that here's what I like the NFL because
someone's getting paid n-c-double-a
you're basically watching Django with
football helmets you know I'm saying
yeah I think you might be onto something
there I like um what do I like in C
double-a Tom Brady's 48 years old and
he's gonna pay 21 million a season now
he's just busting nuts and a supermodel
throwing touchdowns that's why I like
the NFL I also got the Cleveland Browns
they were [ __ ] two years ago now there's
a [ __ ] well we'll see if they're good
okay
they also have one of the biggest egos
in the game or they'll become and
whatever the other guys
[ __ ] the guys from just could you
interview the guy from last chance you
don't talk football
okay first of all I might be your daddy
okay the same cloth vote I saw I saw an
interview of both you guys had the same
answer they say what's the number one
thing you overcame this year you both
said a Quentin Tarantino movie I don't
even get that joke but I'll say this
dude that you um he didn't coach
Division five foot what I'll say is this
dude the NFL I think is I like watching
that end product a little bit better
because I think I was just raised more
in it as a Saints fan but you want to
LSU fan college football I was a little
bit but not crazy there's nothing like
big-time college football you just said
you know hold on hold on you got the
bands playing you got the alumni there
yeah you got the Boosters
I agree nobody getting paid set for the
college yeah and the kids aren't jaded
really so they're playing for the love
of the [ __ ] LSU Tigers or yeah we're
out of buffalos however it's a little
sad though it is sad you know most of
them gonna go on do [ __ ] last chance
you most likely but most of them I think
you're still getting the dreamers out
there at the certain point with the NFL
it gets a little bit different
especially with the contracts um as big
as they are in the NFL or most these
guys even still playing the play or they
just playing to stay in the pay in the
pay grade I don't give a [ __ ] I think
you do that once that's what if we hear
any ones don't care I think some of that
gets effective once it's like oh [ __ ] if
I play so hard that I'm gonna kill
myself or that I'm gonna get hurt then
am I gonna play as hard because I gotta
be back next year to make the money it's
like you got to come back and make the
money whereas college yeah I think you
still get a lot of action Jackson's out
there you know a lot of people that are
in it for the love of the game
I'm gonna go college I'll go to college
dude I'm gonna NFL just because like I
said college is 12 years of slave with
football helmets on I don't [ __ ] with it
yeah but college is also a lot of those
guys wouldn't even be going to college
if for more for football so it's like
that's not a good argument that's not
the slave drivers say
seho well they're getting education no
they're not they're majoring in football
no some of those do scam and read and
they get degrees then that don't learn
[ __ ] if they don't want to learn to read
that's their [ __ ] [ __ ] bro no it's
not because they're not encouraging to
read or encourage them catch footballs
they're encouraged millions of dollars
off of them look I agree the college to
make it money they should share with the
players I agree with that but I don't
think that the players shouldn't be held
accountable at all they don't want to
get education then look here's the thing
they either make it to the pros or let's
be honest if you're a tall black guy you
go work at the airport after so one of
the other bro but I'm just saying it's
my say we got to take responsibility for
ourselves it's like you know anything
colleges fault to [ __ ] gig you know
give you an education now I would demand
that they give you four years whether
you get injured or not that you get to
finish your degree no matter what some
of them do
I would demand that and I think some of
these guys should have more negotiating
I think they should get a fund that you
know five years down the road or two
years or whenever that they start
getting paid you let's see if they're
selling jerseys oh dude you kidding me
the college's making so much money bro
and then the colleges don't care if
people get educated anymore that just
becomes about football no they don't
care as long as you're moving tickets
also they'll be cool and the teachers
let you pass class is in season soon
seasons done you're [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah dude I remember uh oh [ __ ]
I don't even remember you think you
played football for twenty nine sixty
nine percent wait with NFL yes there's
no different animal it's not it you
don't feel a sleazy watch it like you
know those dudes are gonna have brain
trauma in four years it's kind of what
you signed up for I like when people
complain a brain trauma the NFL are
fighting it's like complain [ __ ] yeah
then you got sugar on your shirt if you
a baker
you [ __ ] baker you eat here you're
[ __ ] Michael Phelps you get wet
save your car oh that's I'm saying a lot
of this [ __ ] everybody just find that
that's what happens man you know they're
warriors yeah dude I know if I come on
King in the sting I'm gonna say dumb
[ __ ] from working with you you know and
you're gonna say dumb [ __ ] is what
happens when we get together that's what
we do yeah dude I ain't gonna follow a
lawsuit in two years at us oh man I was
saying all this dumb [ __ ]
a couple of dumbasses Knicks we got
Randy from Harrisonburg wait hold up you
got something real boy do you like
n-c-double-a or NFL let me NFL man and I
fell but I mean I do agree with the Oh
Debbi yeah they should pay the players
and all that but you know hey learn to
read bruh oh yeah take a second out
that's not how it's brought up they
don't force it on you your major in
football if they were to fail you should
learn to read that's you even caves in
hieroglyphics they had a couple little
words up there cat lamp fire alien yeah
pyramid well the reading signs though
you know I'm saying yeah but you watch a
lot mean that some of these kids they
don't give a [ __ ] about they you know if
you know that one out of 300 guys makes
it out of college and you gotta do a
little bit of your studying man yeah
with you man you're preaching I did a my
cuz you take another side I'm just
telling you how it is for the majority
of them yeah I went through the program
I know exactly what the [ __ ] they're
doing I got a double major cuz I knew my
ass wasn't go to the end did you yeah
that's your mom I bet you were in some
shitty band I bet is there any the
pictures of you playing ball let's keep
this [ __ ] train moving this is a
Randy boys we got Randy from
Harrisonburg big Randy what's up Brendon
what's up you know coming at you from
Harrisonburg Virginia and I got a debate
club for you guys today last time you
guys were debating on cinema I don't
want to know what you guys think about
if you're gonna watch a Western are you
gonna watch a John Wayne uestion are you
gonna watch Clint Eastwood western gang
gang buzz-buzz and for Derek and cat
culture culture culture culture culture
here's the thing the real question is
who's more racist
John Wayne bro what are your deal man
that's the race right now I'm just
saying we go back in time also here's
the thing weird they racists or is that
just the way it was back then for John
Wayne that was just the time
yeah well bring up John Wayne tweets and
[ __ ] do they really yeah yeah drag him
under the bus don't pun intended no I'm
just saying John Wayne had Twitter but
they tried to drag him under the bus for
saying like [ __ ] against black people in
1930 what record I think he was in 1930
yeah yeah what I mean it yeah it just
never ends at a certain point people are
[ __ ] if you dragging people through
the past for their and he's dead also
Clint Eastwood's 90 still in movies
direct and during the damn thing and
Clint Eastwood you want to talk about
bus lamps his entire world was a bus
lamp he [ __ ] plane stewardess he [ __ ]
restaurant owners not he has so many
kids yeah hell yeah dude that's Clint
Eastwood to me it's Clint Eastwood all
day I didn't grow up with John Wayne
well that's all I understand was the 30s
he's definitely racist well first of all
dude if you were alive in the 30s you
would probably be racist too dude all
right yeah more he made Million Dollar
Baby
he made the mule which I [ __ ] hated
but either way he directed and starred
in it and he's 97 years old dude at a
certain point let's quit saying starred
in it as opposed to wander around the
set it's getting a little bit wild right
and they just I think this is an unfair
topic because most of our listeners and
even myself barely know John Wayne is
great you know John Wayne II think it's
a porn guy you know yeah I thought John
Wayne was in black I thought John Wayne
was the guy who banged Farrah Abraham's
but I respect this guy and um yes what
doesn't miss either bro he makes great
movies I'm too young for John Wayne I'd
have no I couldn't name one movie all I
know is he got brought up recently in
the news for being racist and he's got
30 so he gets a pass but it's also the
news everybody's racist in the news the
news is a bunch of [ __ ] breach
you know what the news we're right now I
[ __ ] them up bro yeah me too in this
would I give you CNN you [ __ ] gang
bro 73% Eastwood yeah no one knows the
Eastwood dude also your name is Clint
Rowe it's like
with an in in it his son is an actor -
yeah oh wow you know about a son dude I
have no idea about Clint Eastwood son
dude cuz I'm talking about I'm thinking
about chicks over here it's broke tap
alpha tax bro I'm tapping tattoos dude
not dik over there dude it's just a
reference price on your head bro your
[ __ ] brain is gay bro along dicks we
got Jeff from Oklahoma City oh yeah
praise God
okay see ya I'm look at that main bro
Gang Gang buzz-buzz yeah what's going on
is Jeff here from Oklahoma City
Jeff sighs [ __ ] got a debate club topic
for yes Jeff you sell important mr.
Brendan Schwab dawg
when you're flying on a commercial
airline flight are you grabbing that
[ __ ] gonna window seat are you
looking for that [ __ ] aisle
seat word good question anyways you know
what it is
Gang Gang Bulls [ __ ] boys do that
whiskey sales ah bro here's the thing
I'm a Road Dogg I'm on the road non-stop
I'm window only bro I know you been a
Road Dogg for 17 years way to go way to
go I'm on the window bro so I can
snuggle up get a nap in the aisle
I'm Way too thick for the ain't nobody
getting drinks mice in the aisle if
there's an emergency no one's getting
out I take up too much room bro that she
asked me sit in the window oh you're the
tall little cam dude I wouldn't put you
on the [ __ ] aisle
find nothing bro I want to put you in
the merge here every time I say yeah I'm
like bug no I'm getting out first if you
hand me one baby I'll take it but I wait
an employee
yeah you better come with that baby with
that quickness
yeah dude if you sitting in the back
like some [ __ ] some lazy fat adaptil
dude then you're going down you're going
down with time bro you're falling the
time got science no bro I feel you I go
Windows man I like being by the window -
one time - I was on a flight it was a
small plane and they we hit a goose or
something with the propeller and it
bounced down the side of the plane and
it was pretty cool you could just write
down the side and when we got there and
parked it was when we had to get out on
the jet onto the tarmac and walk out it
down a little stairs and they had the
goose feathers in the prop I had a
little bit of blood on the side see
that's entertainment have to pay for and
that's hunting bro depends where yeah
you could have ate that bird yeah that's
something saying put a net on the back
of this [ __ ] and less eat when we land
that's not bad I did a little barbecue
in your land Gang Gang boys in the front
in the back all right let's keep it
let's keep involving 65% went with the
window as well here's the thing - what
savages be farting on the plane we all
got to breed that ear and bro I want a
guy up once he said Joe you got to stop
though you're sitting in front of me
yeah you have to
oh I shook him I said I know what you I
didn't what'd he say I said I know what
you and he cut he said I know it's you
that's the Lord's work and that was it
dude and he stopped after that he done
it 11 times right dude and his [ __ ]
wife was sitting next to me could tell
that he beat his wife and never let her
have a say he's not gonna say it [ __ ]
you could tell she'd never said anything
she'd been smelling probably thousands
of them and then I saw him at the
[ __ ] baggage check out and I'm
[ __ ] looking down right well look
fart magnet yeah [ __ ] hot anymore the
bomber what's up bro yeah dude I hope
somebody farts in your [ __ ] casket I
don't see yet we got some relationship
advice boys changing the world
one bit at a time have you guys this is
Pat from Sydney Australia this is Pat
today passed right out to the Brisbane
Lions were on an insane win streak hey
what's up foes
first of all cambrie buzz buzz and I'm
just a lot here from Australia I just
hated show some love and appreciation
for cat to go in the back gang gang gang
beat damn he says you should be mindful
I got a question for you all but he said
super serious and creepy whatever
there's a girl that I had a casual
sexual arrangement with yeah a dog with
friends Vanessa from Tom's and then
she's introduced me to another one of
her friends who's is really cute not I
think I I've know pretty well and I
think I might like her a little bit more
than that but I'm worried about hurting
my original friend's feelings have you
got need advice for me about how I go
about this cheese well let's ask Erin
buzz buzz down under let's ask your uh
that's the [ __ ] wife yeah Cat Cat what
should he do let's talk about your
Australian crush right now I think he
should just tell her because how does he
know that she actually likes him and
isn't just [ __ ] him
yeah no one's moving forward are they
yeah feelings for each other they're
just [ __ ] hmm I'd have to know how
long he can hook it up yeah cats
ruthless with it huh God cat yeah but
you cared a little more Gang Gang cut
cut no very nice gentleman yeah he just
seemed friendly I'd have to know how
long they've been bumping in there
grinding you know if it's a long time at
it off see ain't going nowhere so [ __ ]
the friend you know I'm saying house
nuts down under but if it's your friend
no not bus nuts down under Brendan
what's it like nine year old has been
watching too much pornography dog or
Derek yeah what I'm saying is I think
this guy you can't just [ __ ] your
friend's friend all the time man okay
why not because you're gonna lose your
friend maybe it's Australia yeah things
happen there just like to happen
everywhere Brendan okay it's not a
mythical place in time they're not
actors so I think you have to try and
you got to talk to the friend say hey
what are your friend thing you know or
let the sexual situation with your first
friend run out before you take that
opportunity before you try to decide too
long bro just tell the hot friend that
you're banging for all this time you
know your friend is hot we should
include her see what she says he's young
yeah it's true it's like the movie you
or the show you for you next thing you
know you're doing drugs you got eyeliner
on your conten - dude youyou don't know
there's techno but you're down under
that shows her tits I heard it's
horrible oh that's fantastic
really seems like you would like it yeah
I do I love it yeah well you remind me
go watch it then you remind me of the
dad in it yeah that's fine dude go watch
it you're the dad in it yeah fine
you're a buckle bunny I haven't seen it
well this guy should see it and he
should take notes from it and try and
[ __ ] both of them Derek what do you
think dude you've obviously ruined a
white girl's life by busting or
constantly do you have my friend yeah I
agreed he should James Bond that [ __ ]
let's try to get both of them man you
know all you guys are disgusting discuss
our culture culture this guy - he's
young looks like Leo DiCaprio down under
wants a fostering some tears make sure
you take care of your [ __ ] buddy friend
bro if you [ __ ] all your buddies then
you don't have any buddies dude you
never had a boomerang okay and he don't
give a [ __ ] whatever I'll do a threesome
with these chicks sometime boys watch
Crocodile Dundee and [ __ ] both of them
yeah that's what I said shout out to the
Brisbane Lions brush Dundee that hitter
gang that hitter nobody even remembers
[Laughter]
now that's a knife no I don't remember
that dude shout out to shout out to
somebody that's better that's Australian
that's more recent Oh
shot who is Austrian shout out to Oh
Thor
Chris Hemsworth is Australian shout out
to Wolverines Australian shout out to
Gallipoli shut up - Toni Kukoc oh he's
Australian Australian dude who
correlation you might be right on that
yeah Longley though is uh yeah shout out
to Luc Longley man oh shout to BJ
Simmons is the Australian really up to
Kyrie Irving also Australian no Ben
Simmons what I say for this Japanese
sexers yeah Ben Simmons is Australian
yeah he's also seem like an egomaniac
that didn't even try and ecology we talk
about players not doing [ __ ] in college
he tell us shoot for one season that's
how bad he was you don't even [ __ ]
remember it and they didn't even make
the n-c-double-a his bro give a [ __ ]
he's waiting for all the millions well
[ __ ] dude he's all-star well then if
you don't give a [ __ ] dude then [ __ ] him
bro that's what I'm sayin dawg well he's
[ __ ] something it's Kardashian let
him do whatever he wants brah you're
hating on him dude he accused him of
being racist he laid a casino and he's
white well he's more white he's
definitely more white than we are
yeah he's Australian white yeah dude
that's double white yeah you right
that's why they got a great white prom
down hello rip my trip boys up first
this is awesome that's that Bret the
Hitman hit her did you see that yeah
dawg pretty dope you see the Cu one they
made me that's the emblem my college
degree that's the closer you get to a
college steel is it close you're getting
to a diplomas like this thing for an
hour
smells like you should have finished all
your credits this is beautiful oh it
smells like home school won't light it
up bro
is this the candle guy yeah that's
Canada is it yeah we'll just go again uh
candles are us
Bruno model by mockery candle Co some
[ __ ] like that yeah I don't know but
this party has come to a screeching halt
sorry let's go up first this is Tyler
Dalrymple and with his family on
vacation at Lake Erie
[Music]
the kid looks terrified in the front I'd
be terrified too if I was matching
clothes like an [ __ ]
I hate when parents dressed the kids the
same ask the kid I ask my kids so you
want dressed like me I look like a
dumbass you want dressed like this he
goes hell no we don't dress like that
yeah first of all beautiful family great
family I've got four people in your
family that's easy to count easy to deal
with clearly the baby's kidnapped look
at the face uh clearly the baby is grew
from Despicable Me so let's be honest
and they got or actually a little baby
looks like Derek even looks a tad like
Derek and GRU had a baby there might
have been busting some minions yeah
definitely they got and a little girl
looks just like um Cabbage Patch yeah
yeah well cabbage patches of nice one
yeah Cabbage Patch yeah yeah and then
you got the beautiful mommy right there
and you got your family where it seemed
like a rural area there's no way to get
home from this big another beach or the
camping Lake Erie oh yeah and that's
that's a beautiful family right there it
almost looks like those dolls where one
is little inside of the other yeah yeah
it look good when those Mexican toys
were the oh boo boo boo Boop yeah the
might rice montmatre shkadov Russia
Russian dollar Russia
everything is Mexican Mexicans listen
Mexicans even make those what are we
talking about they probably do make them
yeah they make all but the rustic great
call yeah same with vodka they ain't
making that [ __ ] yeah like I look at
these Chinese shirts we have certainly a
great point
yeah man it's like oh yeah look at these
cherry things Chinese man iced out those
family though yeah nice family they look
like they decent everybody's healthy
looks like that mom's tatted up if
you've noticed
yeah they got his mom also has a fun
side oh yeah the Hawaiian shirts didn't
let you know they liked that fun that
tattoo of the mom does but the four
matching shirt seems a little bit
Elizabeth Smart to me like you got a
yeah a little Manson family yes yeah -
were you guys can be match and I think
you gotta let two people wear their own
stuff
two out of the four but let the kids
decide mom and dad you can dress the
same let the kids have a choice here's
the thing that when you went to
Disneyland the other week did you notice
how many people are dressed the same
yeah it's crazy it is crazy insane it's
like a thing there that the family you
have to get your family shirt you have
to have your Disney shirt yeah that's in
case you lose them that's how you know
got shitty parents mmm mix we got Corey
this is Corey god damn Corey need a
Ferrari
what is up girl says big brown can get
it all day an exclamation point mark -
damn we got us brainy one on our hands -
do we yeah cuz she loves me
I'll tell you what she can throw me an
Instagram story though yeah she
definitely looks really really cute in
this picture just four fingers on one
hand five fingers on the other hand and
she's off see that's that's just a okay
carry is a courier carry do we know
I'm gonna guess from her face car is she
a real person cuz that body's out of
this world give it up call our Brendan
and quit using this is some sort of love
connection Cory okay this is a
professional show and obviously I'm just
jealous that she didn't mention me but
that's fine we'll have some dude
defending your next well here's a candor
Brendan allegedly went to college most
people get a diploma not a gift from
their power
damas am still jealous I'm just making
have your mom read off what classes you
guys let's call your mom pop alright
boys gonna end it with some king of
stinging wrap it up there first this is
Adam from Cape Town South Africa
beautiful we're going international big
mr. worldwide
what's up there what's up Brandon this
is Adam coming to you from sunny Cape
Town South Africa you know you know what
it is the king of the sting it for you
slacklining Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz
buzz that's some white [ __ ] in there
black honey have you ever seen anyone
but a white person walk a line like that
answer you ever seen in the servicing
cops dude a lot of black dudes doing it
okay yeah and I'm gonna talk about that
Johnny Cash I think it's a universal
sport
I definitely don't you ever seen the
circus that's a good point let's go to
the culture corner and find out is rope
walk in a black or white event is it
cultural what's going on yes cultural
has the widest sure I have yet to see
anybody but a white person knew it
really it says why does it [ __ ] blink
182 concert yeah the only black person
Adam was a little Wayne and he [ __ ]
left high and dry the only two black
people ever Chapelle Lacey and little
Wayne and little wings out there's like
some Chinese girl somewhere out there
doing it right now though yeah somewhere
I feel like if there's anyone to do it
like a tiny Chinese girl mmm Chinese
they call it no the Chinese it's white
dough it's a skill I guess it also takes
a lot of time I mean a lot of time it's
way quicker than going all the way down
stairs and walking across the street and
going all the way upstairs if you have a
rope yeah you're right you're right it's
definitely a white sport
slacklining
[Music]
it's brave man is it he's two feet off
the ground okay it's not that brave now
for you to do in the circus you can do
it from building to building no burgers
mouth yeah for you to be spider-man with
it
Tarzan I'm with it yeah but if you're
just in your backyard above your [ __ ]
flower guard and calling it dangerous
yeah yeah especially in your country in
South Africa that uh you got to hit up
um they have one of the largest bungee
jumps in the whole world I think it's
they're actually off the boo Krenz
bridge or something see where it's at
hey would you all jump huh would you
ever bunch yeah I've done it a couple
times I wouldn't do it again it's for
dum-dums man I wouldn't do it again it's
always now it's always like over there
and you know Pompano Beach or something
or Delray Beach now it's in Cancun it's
at the blue cranes bridge ching hai's
bungees in the world it's fourth yeah
Derrick using his motor skills obviously
he was on scholarship with it was it
struggle city or was it struggle thank
you youtube it over there but tell us
about it Derek it's the blue Cron's
bridge bungy it's the world's highest
commercial bungee at two hundred and
sixteen meters that's seven hundred and
nine feet yeah walk across that bro and
get back to me I had a chance to go on
this one time I chickened out because
just you're smart ish yeah just I think
I had too much bad experiences in
America where it's like some guys like
oh you can handle it you know and you
hook she has you hooked up and then one
guys like otters jumpy like hold on we
got a hook do you see the guy whose cord
broke see that uh there is Reese in the
news I forget where I saw you jump the
cord is like nine up not up in here
broke lettuce went straight to the
ground but there was a thing to catch
him underneath he broke his back neck
he's still alive breaking my back
breaking my nose cords in the front row
in the back
no bro but yeah man it you're in the
you're in a country that has X Games are
thriving over there dude I think put
that slackline you know how about this
take it from your wife's bedroom window
y'all's bedroom window over to the
neighbors window start somewhere
see ya that liner yeah real neighbors
get risky brah
you know how the same time like you're
super risky start doing over the ocean
with all them goddamn great whites
jumping out of the water
barely a sight Oh put a little risk in
your Triscuit bro you feel me Dawg yeah
dang man up next we got Rob from London
from London
and they rub yeah what's up Jesus Christ
Derek from London what are you bumping
us on 22s man unbelievable with goddess
oh good can we start over T month sounds
oh good scared from the vientos a
shooting yeah what's up my name's Rob
from London England Rob name ever
roasting it this week is organs that
double keyboard hitter
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's from 1915
give him a minute yeah let me know what
you guys think also Brendan mate you
look like your ancestors recently
started coming out of the case where
they've been living via a Hewlett like
your ancestors have recently stopped
getting eaten by Brendan's ancestors
[Laughter]
September Manchester game bro gang game
buzz buzz all the best boys man here's
the thing or again I from 1915 also the
only organ I want to see is in [ __ ]
wha
God what is it Oh Phantom of the Opera
yeah that's the only time it's cool bro
we're getting I like Phantom of the
Opera is here
inside of me that [ __ ] made users plate
non-stop really yeah I know the whole
album for so Wow weird
the only time I hear organ I'll tell you
what you ain't getting no [ __ ] playing
that thing do you know one likes that
thing you know a lot of dick I don't
think so I think you're [ __ ] a lot of
ghost if you got that thing bro you're
gonna be busted a lot of [ __ ] you'd
be busting Queen Mary the third oh
you're gonna be [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
as bats in it you know you got that
beautiful organ dude that dude organ one
of the top three instruments of the
1920s John before that seventeen a
hundred you don't play that instrument
not drop the n-word every day we had it
do you might be right
you might be right you might be right we
had it man and the rapper's took it from
us no they did and the only claim it is
thirst
um I what I do appreciate its unique
okay I like that and maybe he can catch
up go spy in his web look any chick that
ever liked that movie with Robert
Pattinson in it yeah game [ __ ] them
right Twilight yeah
[Laughter]
so yeah obviously to see to roll up to a
Bram Stoker convention with that thing
in the bag with the vampire with his
dick I'm in bro
yeah bro you got it dude I think I'm
gonna say King in on Oregon I'm like
Kenya - all right our last one this is
from Jace from Salt Lake City Utah
what's up Theo gang gang baby Brennan
get that hair right boy
this is Jace from Salt Lake City Utah
and I had a king of sting it for you
here today dick bandit was listening to
crystal you're talking about these
hookers with a premium snapchat you're
paying for something you get for free
all over the internet all day every day
qinger stinging Premium snapchats I
gotta go take care of some business my
boys look at the guy's ass cuz it's in
my face his girl said buzz buzz did you
notice that yeah she said gang gank he
did with that same premium snapchats are
they just like they're usually just used
for hookers how do you guys feel need
one obviously if he's got his lady over
all the time just collect that's his
last or that's a premium snapchat girl
like if the lefty were to say I'm out of
control
I'll see you a gamer look at that see
you noticed the seed bro you wanna see
him I call of duty or the [ __ ] you plant
midnight we all crying with your tears
see this dude
these pants are off bro yeah I haven't
met him on there well you should be
friends I feel like he likes you well
he's going to spend down with his lady I
think that that's pretty quiet they're
still together what was he asking about
he said Krista leo premium snapchat you
know what do you think I mean here's the
thing you something.if once you put it
behind a paywall or something there's
value to it you know it's like what do
you mean that's when there's value it's
like you just see if people will pay for
you can put anything my nappy behind I
think you got to pay for it it's a [ __ ]
move
you know I'm saying well I think it's a
[ __ ] for some podcasts go behind a
paywall
but a lot of a lot of performers they
you know a lot of these porn stars and
stuff who are doing it they don't have a
way to really make money these agencies
are making a lot of the money and the
poor market is oversaturated so there's
no way for them to really make any money
[ __ ] so that's why they do it now I
get it I get it I get it you can just
watch porn you don't have to pay them to
send you pictures and videos you know
I'm saying just watch that chill porn
she's already really paying for on
snapchat what she can show you an ass
shot maybe some titties or I can show to
you porn type in her name and watch my
boy big black dick or - Jesus that's
premium quality give it up bro no dude I
wouldn't take me so it's more talking
about porn porn you're the one who
watches you well you're not allowed -
yes I am allows and I choose not to I
make a choice not to put pornography
into my brain not me I'll watch it but
if I wore I'm not watching a bunch of
brothers do it okay I'll watch a little
maxine guy I'll watch a Filipino guy
standing on another Filipino guy's
shoulders okay
I try to do go above and beyond each
other the only easy to lazy porn another
black guy banging a white chick you
right bro taking the easy way out I like
to watch a struggling white guy try to
[ __ ] a white chick okay confession in
taxi driver picks up some timepiece and
he's like you know if you don't want pay
your fare and then she works at all bro
that's every taxi driver in Vegas - if
you always ask him hey is some chick
ever pay you in sex oh yeah oh yeah I
don't know what do you think about this
cat let's get a female perspective we're
just obviously a couple dudes at
jerk-off all the time I don't do it a
lot there doesn't your coffee busting
this girl but me and Theo Jarek
definitely jerks off dude I don't Thanks
Derek seems like the guy that also jerks
off and Derek seems like the guy that
jerks off into his girl
I don't see the appeal of doing a
premium snapchat unless you're obsessed
with like a particular person you can do
it though cat like you could do a
premium chat yeah your feet my feet do
gardening with your feet yeah oh that's
you could you could roll croissants with
your feet yeah if you did some different
types of dough's or something yeah you
know I'm saying like make a nice
sourdough bread with your feet
yeah quoi song Kos song I would see I
wouldn't maybe a blueberry muffin yeah
how long can you keep charging people
for it you'd be surprised
that's a special look man how long he
keep charging people for it
aspirin demand for years never in it
might never end and maybe you should it
and maybe it can we get those guys white
ass off of the screen that might be the
best video we've got he's growing us
here I like you though man like a fan of
yours Oh nuts
a hairy ass don't do it stuff back there
man but I'll uh you know I'll stay all
king priam snapchat if that's the way
you got to make money whether it's
[ __ ] you got dicks on there your
titties whatever man get your money yeah
if there's a market for it that's on
them yeah and then also it brings the
market back into their it's their market
it's not just the poor instead my corner
brassiere is taking 90 percent while
you're getting loads on your face
exhausted every night yeah you're
getting out here loaded out dude you're
getting loaded up like a damn whirlpool
you know stackable [ __ ] machine you
know you [ __ ] running loads like a
damn laundromat greased up like it's
Jiffy Lube again ten percent yeah you
deserve to get your money girls yeah
you're an Orange Julius much of your
money so what was this teen premium
accounts get your money [ __ ] Pat my
Pat one [ __ ] chapter this show might
never know what's going on
under snow we all have fleas man well
you wrapped it up today boy that's it
yeah why don't you wrap it up a town for
a birthday to get a [ __ ] break that's
anti Agra falls bro give her a break
price her girl what do you want for your
birthday should I just need a break yeah
I need an umbrella sick of being
dripping wet bro where are we coming up
I don't even know I'm in Memphis I'm in
Atlanta this week Birmingham a couple of
different places theof on.com slash tour
yeah I'm in Portland this Thursday
Friday Saturday with Derrick poster and
Chappelle Lacey then I'm at the ice
house that Sept 10 September up the ice
house Derrick probably there as well and
some other friends get any feel being
down be poppin yeah that'd be cool dude
I'll let the ice house and then it's you
spin Denver get your tickets at T fat K
calm Gang Gang buzz drop I'm sorry I I
busted that's on my mind culture culture
culture culture
can I say
[Music]